Hello, and welcome to today's episode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
InfluxDB
two and the Flux language.
Now before we do that, I wanna say
thank you to Equinix Medal for providing the
time and resources for me to put this
show together so that we can learn from
experts around the world about all these cool
cloud native technologies.
Now joining me today to look at InfluxDB,
I have Anais Dottis Georgia from Influx Data.
How are you, Anais?
I'm doing well. Thanks. How are you?
Yeah. I'm very well. Thank you. Would you
like to firstly take a moment just to
introduce yourself, tell us a little bit about
you, and then we'll talk about InfluxDB.
Sure.
So I'm a developer advocate at InfluxData,
and I've been at InfluxData for about two
and a half years now.
A little bit about me and then a
little bit about InfluxData
in general. Well, I guess a little bit
more about me. I have two really cute
cats.
Their names are Chester and Nikita, and they're
always snuggling, which is adorable.
And I like to make art and
get outside and feel the sunshine as much
as I can.
And then a little bit about InfluxData.
So InfluxData
is a platform for building and operating time
series applications.
And it consists of two parts, InfluxDB,
which is the database and processing engine, and
then also the UI.
And then the second bit is Telegraph,
which is a
collection agent for metrics and events.
So
should we get into using InfluxDB,
or do you wanna learn some about
some interesting customer use cases or how are
you feeling?
Well, why don't we do the little bit
of setup work that's involved first, then we'll
talk about
some of those things and then by the
magic of the Internet and time, we'll have
what we need to get started. So Perfect.
I put up the InfluxDB
website which we'll use to download it, but
before we do that, we do need some
hardware. So we're gonna spin up a new
server.
And this is Equinix metal, so it's all
bare metal goodness. I'll spin this up in
Amsterdam.
Now does it matter what size of machine
we use?
No. It doesn't really. Let's just use an
expensive one anyway. Makes it more fun.
Let's go with it been to 20.
In fact, let's pick a faster provisioning one,
twenty o four.
And we'll call this InfluxDB.
I always like to make sure that I
don't really do anything upfront so that people
can kind of follow along. We won't do
any user data here. We're just gonna spin
this up as a vanilla Linux machine, and
then we'll walk through the installation steps.
Now hopefully this will refresh. The box is
spinning up and that is gonna take one
to two minutes. So why don't
you give us one to two minutes of
awesome information about maybe what's new with InfluxDB
two. I believe that was GA, was it,
last week?
Yeah. And then if you want, you can
feel free to share some user stories if
you wish. Sure. So InfluxDB
two is
quite different from the one dot x
line.
Primarily, it's that previously,
all the components of the platform are separated
and now they've been unified
from four components into two. And so the
collection agent is separate, but all the capabilities
of the UI and the data processing and
task engine and the actual time series database
is now just one unified,
component.
So
that's one part. And then the other thing
that we introduced with, or the not me,
but engineers introduced with the two dot o
is that they
created Flux, which is a functional
query and scripting language for
time series in particular. It's kinda JavaScript esque,
and you can do a lot of fancy
things with it and it, like, takes your
data
and allows you to play with it in
what sort of feels much more relational than
it than it is.
Just extends
all like, a bunch of functionality to working
and analyzing your data.
And I will say when I first started
learning it, it took
a little second for me to get used
to it. But then once I got accustomed
to it, don't even understand how people do
things in SQL anymore.
It's just too many parentheses, too many nested
queries, and I really prefer Flex. So
you definitely have a shift in thinking, but
once you get used to it, then it's
a lot more comfortable.
Some cool stories.
If I still have time do I have
time?
You've got time. Okay.
Cool.
A cool story is well, recently, the Ruben
Observatory
is doing some awesome work work with InfluxDB.
So they are trying to if I remember
correctly, I'm not
that well versed in physics and star stuff.
So
apologies if I get it wrong, but I
think they're trying to prove the existence of
dark matter. And so they're doing a ten
year survey of the sky and they're collect
collecting 500 petabytes of
images of the sky with, I think, the
world's largest telescope.
And
they're using Influx to both monitor their telescope,
and I think they're actually also collecting some
some image related metadata as well with it.
But 500 petabytes, that's fun.
Yeah. Yeah. That's that's a sizable chunk of
data. That's for sure.
There were a couple of things there that
I I really liked. So of course, the
physics stuff is cool, but that just that
quote of physics and star stuff, think is
now my new go to for describing astronomy.
That is that is no cemented.
And also, I'll I'll share your I don't
know if it was frustration followed by joy
of Flux, but I I remember the first
few times I was trying to write a
Flux script and it it felt like just
banging my head off of a wall. And
then eventually you just I I really struggled
to write queries in any other language, so
I definitely shared that journey with you.
Alright. And right on queue, we have a
machine as well.
So now because
this is an entirely professional production, I did
forget to put this on the screen when
I was spinning up. If anyone wants to
spin up their own Equinix medal, there's $50
coupon from the show code. Feel free to
use it.
So
dot oh no.
There we go. Don't close the tab. So
I'm gonna click get InfluxDB,
we're gonna ignore the pop up, we're gonna
click on 201.
So this is the docker images, the static
binaries that we can just pull this down
onto our machine and get started.
And if I get anything wrong, just interject
and tell me I'm wrong.
Alright. We're good.
So I will copy this
and
where's my terminal?
There we go. Ah, no. I need an
IP address, don't I?
So let's make sure I can get on
my machine.
So I've moved all of my hardware around
and now my fingerprint scanner is over here
which makes it a very smooth move to
get onto my SSH as well. Yeah.
Alright. Let's grab this again.
So we're just going to pull this down,
AMD sixty four debian fail. I mean, I
think that's the right one. Installed.
That's good.
Let's confirm.
Okay. So it's not running, so we could
just just start InfluxDB.
Easy bit. Yeah.
So
this is the new single binary that you
said is is available. This is new with
InfluxDB two. All the components are shipped by
one.
So now I can just browse to this
IP address and we'll get the web interface.
Right?
Hopefully.
There we go. So
let's click getting started.
So this is the setup screen. Right? This
is because InfluxDB
two
can't be unauthenticated,
if I remember correctly?
Correct. Yeah.
And the design team has done really awesome
stuff with integrating tutorials into the UI so
that if you are a beginner like this,
we can just, like,
hit clicks quick start and be walked through
everything that we need.
Alright. Well, choose your own adventure then, I
know. What what what path are we taking
today?
Yeah. Let's do quick start. Let's pretend that
we're we're not an expert already.
Alright. So what did that do?
Looks like it brought us to the getting
starting page
where we have an option to either go
ahead and load our data or build a
dashboard or set up alerting.
But we don't have any data yet, so
let's let's load our data.
Oh, those animations are really stick. I know.
Right?
I also love the color palette.
Yeah. I mean, I'm just gonna sit and
watch that one I think because it's cool
then. Yeah. And Can we do the third
one?
Oh, yeah.
It's not Sorry. What? It's not as good.
Like the second one. Yeah. The second one.
The first two are really good. You know,
this is the important stuff that we need
to kind of break down on this show.
So and I love that randomly or serendipitously,
the color palette actually kind of matches my
shows colors too. Like it's purpley pinkiness.
Alright. So
what are we doing? Are we are we
loading data? Yeah. Let's load our data.
Okay. So this is offering me client libraries,
tell oh, wow.
So I I mean, I should say because
there's gonna be conversations where I say, oh,
I don't remember this. I I we used
to work together in Flux. So I am
familiar with the tool and the languages.
But I have been detached from it for
like what? Six months now? Five months? I
can't remember.
So I'm sure it's changed a lot. But
this is offering us the client libraries that
we have available, which is if we want
to instrument something ourselves, which I'm assuming we're
not doing today. We'll try and
we'll skip that.
Has this telegraph thing which I've definitely not
seen before. Now I'm assuming if I click
on one of these, is it gonna offer
me like a pre canned config for Yeah.
It should.
Yeah. Right. Okay. So I can just copy
that to clipboard, and it tells me a
little bit about the data structure.
Alright. In fact, this just looks like it's
generated from the from the.
Yeah. I think so.
Okay. What's next? What else we got?
Is that it?
Yeah. I think so. So you can also
click Telegraph itself too and generate a new
config that way.
Well, I mean, we know this stuff. We
we can we can manually write a telegraph
config.
Yeah. We can, but you don't have to.
Right. Okay. So let's see. I just click
create configuration.
Either way, I mean
No. Because then I have to remember bits
and stuff and
other non star stuff. So let's just do
it this way. So I'll click system.
Off the top of my head, I'm assuming
we're gonna get CPU,
memory, network, disk.
I'm sure there'll be one or two others.
Okay. System.
Processes swapped.
Yeah. I haven't ever remembered that list. So
this this is probably better.
Oh, there's a nice InfluxDB token for everybody.
With my IP address, it's very public. So
alright.
Export.
Oh, and we don't have Telegraph. Right? So
Oh, yeah. We need to go install Telegraph.
K. App update. App install.
Telegraph. Yes.
Alright. Let's download the binary.
I was sure it was in the
Ubuntu
archives,
but maybe there's an
app repository.
There's a dev fail. There we go. Let's
use that.
Okay.
So we go to slash etc slash telegraph
and
oh, no. We don't, do we? We just
run telegraph with our special flag.
Right. Yeah. And then we can see if
Influx is gathering
data successfully.
Yay.
And it's worth noting too that if you
click setup instructions,
you can follow that again.
So if you like, I don't know if
that's apparent to everyone that that's a button.
And then also,
if you actually click system,
the config itself,
then you have an opportunity to both download
the config and change it if you need
to make adjustments to the configuration.
Alright.
Well, I'm
assuming based on or you see just today,
we'll probably get away with just this this
ten second interval. I mean, could speed it
up, see it a little bit quicker, but
we've already wasted the first ten seconds. I'm
assuming when we go through this explorer view,
we will hopefully have something. So
let's take a look at that.
I've got my bucket here.
Do you wanna just
break down the vocabulary to them for people
that aren't as familiar with InfluxDB? You know,
so far we've mentioned
like the system stuff we're gonna scrape and
then a bucket like
what words and what things do people need
to be familiar with with InfluxDB two especially
compared to Versys one?
So a bucket is a combination of a
database
and a retention policy, all packaged as one
and it's that's known as a bucket. And
I like to think of just if you
have a stream of data
and it's coming into a bucket,
eventually, depending on the size of the data,
it's gonna overfill
and expire some of your old data naturally.
So you can think of the size of
the bucket as the retention policy
and
otherwise a bucket being like a database.
And then after that, we have measurements,
tags, and fields.
Measurements and tags
and buckets are indexed and fields are not.
So that means that if you are writing
to InfluxDB
and let's say,
you're either gonna create your own Telegraph plugin
or you're gonna
you have to make a decision as to
whether or not you want data to be
a tag or a field.
You wanna keep in mind that any queries
that you filter by a specific tag will
be a lot faster than if you filter
by a
specific
field.
And then the other thing to keep in
mind is that
it's much easier to cross compare data that
is in one single measurement
than
than if your data is in separate measurements.
So if your data is very correlated or
related and you need to be able to
visualize
two different fields at the same time frequently,
then you wanna probably put those in the
same measurement.
That being said, one of the cool things
that Flex lets you do is to perform
math cross measurements and join data across measurements
or even buckets.
So that's totally up to you. And then
the other thing worth noting is that you
can scope tokens on the per bucket basis.
So if you're building some sort of IoT
app, for example, and you have
a reason that
security purposes that you want to maybe separate
out
various
data sessions with individual tokens or or users
data with individual tokens, and you can think
about scoping tokens to individual buckets and directing
your data in the way that you see
fit.
So does that is there anything else that
you think I can clarify? Or if we
should we just start I think we should
just start clicking and see what happens, basically,
is my
Yeah. I think you covered everything there that
I I thought of at least that we
should break down. So I think if we
just start clicking now, start exploring this data,
show people kind of how the UI works
and how you discover this stuff, and then
we can try and get a little bit
more
pragmatic after that. So Sure. What's what's your
favorite measurement? I always look at CPU
and then
like usage system.
And then maybe I'll pick two or all
of them. Yeah. Let's just
click go on this. And alright. So right
now, we've got
data.
Yeah. Let's drop this down to five minutes
so that we can there we go. That's
a bit more spread out. So
It's also worth noting that if you look
on the right hand side underneath the submit
button, there's a section there that we've selected
with an aggregate function. So we've applied the
mean
with an auto interval based on
the amount of data that you're querying for.
And this is
just to make the visualization
easier because if you're clearing hundreds of thousands
of points and your data is really noisy,
you're gonna probably wanna apply a trend anyways.
So it does that for you off the
bat.
But if you wanna exclude that, you can
just unclick the mean,
I believe.
No. Computers said can't. Oh, never mind. Well,
then if you go to the script editor,
we can see the query that Flex generated
for us, and then we could always remove
the aggregate function when
function and then hit submit and then we'd
see the raw data without the
the mean.
Do you want to remove the aggregate window?
First, let's let me look maybe we should
just talk about flux and what's going on
here.
So Yeah. Go for it. Yeah. So first,
we're select Let me try and submit on
this because I don't think that's gonna be
particularly
readable. Right? Yeah. That's that's better.
Also, the data with this aggregate window is
really visually pleasing.
It's got a lot of diamonds in it,
which I appreciate. Anyways,
so the way that Flux works is that
you
first specify the bucket that you wanna get
your data from
using the from function.
And then you use pipe forward operators for
every data transformation that you make on your
data. So
I like the pipe forward operators because it
really helps
bring my attention to the fact that I'm
now changing my data and also
is indicative of how the stored engine works
and how the the Flux
engine works and how it operates with push
downs and is pushing down
each,
essentially,
operation
within the Flux engine. So
the first thing we're gonna do is select
a range and
filter for our start and stop times, or
you can just filter for a start time
and say, like, minus five minutes.
You can also manually
put in a time, but this references
the v the variable time range stop references
the click down option that you used previously.
And you can also select a custom date
with that click down option as well.
And then if you ever doing any sort
of forecasting and you wanna look at data
into the future, you would do a stop
time of
just five minutes without a plus or anything.
And then we filter for the measurements and
the fields that we wanna look at.
And then afterwards, we can apply any other
functions that we want.
So, yeah, I guess we can get rid
of the aggregate window to see kinda what
it was doing just for fun.
For fun.
Yeah.
Alright. So I think there's a couple of
really thing. Like a couple of really nice
things that I'd, you know, we don't see
in other programming languages that much but I
know for time series it makes sense and
that's like these duration literals.
Like the five m and the minus five
m I think are really cool.
And you I like the pay forward operator
too. Not that partial to the diamond shape
but you know, I can appreciate it a
little bit.
So we are now ignoring just to make
sure everything is quite clear here by changing
that range statement to be start minus five
and stop five. We're
essentially making this drop down redundant in our
use case. Like I could go back and
see an hour
or actually that no. Changed it because time
has passed. Like seconds have passed since the
last time I did it.
These are
I'm not quick enough.
That is irrelevant.
We've removed the mean
and
we're still getting a graph that looks pretty
much the same.
Is that expected?
With removing the mean?
Yeah.
I don't think so. Maybe I think maybe
because we have so little data that maybe
the mean is
really similar. So maybe if we instead of
doing a window period, I wonder
if we did a window period of one
hour
in the aggregate window if we'd see a
difference.
We well, we don't have a lot of
data yet. But Right. So we would see,
we would expect to see one point.
Okay. So
let's kind of
we pulled data from the bucket. We've set
up our own start and stop range and
we fell through the data. Now we can
have the ability to aggregate and
the calculations.
What else can we do besides just the
mean then? Like, if we were to bring
this back in, what what is a a
good common use case for for aggregate window?
Gosh. That's a hard question because it it's
one of those things that feels obvious.
And just because if you're close to it,
you
and then stepping back and trying to explain
it is harder.
I would just say I would say
one common use
would maybe be
for also downsampling your data. So if you
have really high resolution data
and
you decide that after a certain time
that that high resolution data is no longer
valuable to you and you're only concerned with
overall
patterns in the data rather than than the
granular
granular shape of it, then you might create
a downsampling task with the aggregate window
to pull that data in in a in
a
lower resolution form,
and only save that and then expire the
old data so that you can
reduce your overall resources and disco disc space.
So that's one one reason. I think I
use aggregate window when I just want to
smooth the data when I'm clearing it so
I can better understand overall trends in my
data.
But you also have a a window function
as well
in case you need to
maybe window data and then
perform unions across windows or
I mean, really, what you what you do
with the Flux is kinda it's so dependent
on your use case and what, you know,
data transformation is all about,
what your data is, what you're trying to
achieve, what insights you're trying to get out
of it. So it's so specific.
Okay.
That that that that makes sense. Like, I
I understand that. So now
people have the choice. Right? They can
they can just use the query builder and
probably get a substantial way through what they
need to do at least from a a
superficial level without really ever rate in flux.
Is that a fair
fair statement? Yeah. I think so.
For sure.
Alright. Well, let's see if we can go
back to it just now. So we explored
our CPU.
Oops.
Why don't we take a look at one
more thing?
And then we'll do some dashboard y bits.
So
there's quite a lot in here.
How about we look at one of the
InfluxDB ones?
What do we got?
Whatever the rate stats are. Do you know?
What about them?
Well, maybe that's it there. Let's try that.
Go.
Yeah. Okay. That's gonna I just wanted to
see like because we've got telegraph which is
on the loop which is writing data every
ten seconds. We should see this linear
growth of the number of frames. Okay.
But it's also not that exciting to show.
So let's pick one more.
How about the memory consumption?
Because I'm zoomed in, that makes it a
little bit tricky. And we don't need this
flux script right now. So
so that's
mem.
We've got all the go runtime stuff.
We've got memory here. So let's take a
look at
available percent.
And you can see I'm assuming here that
just because we are writing to InfluxDB
which has an end memory right ahead log,
That's why our memory is dropping.
And
we're just looking at available with that. Well,
that's not very good.
Alright. Okay. So the query builder is quite
cool. We can drop down to Flux when
we need it.
Shall we try
a
dashboard, some of those, and see if we
can understand what a healthy Linux system looks
like? Sure.
So if you go back to the explorer,
you can actually click
oh, yeah. Click your
measurement that you want. Alright. Let's do CPU
first. Right? So Okay.
So, like, I think the intended workflow here
is that once I mean, there's a million
ways to skin a cat. That's so dark.
But once you
once you find your query and you're happy
with it in the explore tab, then you
can click the right hand little button that
says save as, and you can kinda save
it as a dashboard if I remember correctly.
So we are did we add that? No.
So I created it for you. Yeah.
Alright. Well, we'll create a new one just
now, and then we'll we'll take a look.
So we'll call this system
manual,
and we'll call this CPU.
It would be nice if it took me
to the dashboard.
I'll make a note.
There
we go.
Alright.
What else will we add? Will we do
memory again then?
Yeah. And disk
maybe.
Yeah. Well, disk is something that's relatively easy
for us to
destroy quickly.
Put that in there and
memory.
I really should just use a search, shouldn't
I?
Mem
let's do just available.
Let's add used.
Now these don't look terribly exciting just now
because
I probably threw too big a box at
this and we're not really, we're barely tackling
it, I would say right now. So
let's
cause a little bit of trouble.
Well, they pop
open another
shell,
then we can say
rate
from
random
to a fail called big fail.
And that should
just keep writing random bytes to the disk.
So
what
what's happening here with telegraph, right, is that
it's scraping metrics every ten seconds, drag them
to InfluxDB.
Our dashboard is not all refreshing, but we'll
just set that on ten seconds now anyway.
We'll look at the last five minutes and
I'm assuming we should see some movement on
some of these cells. Right?
Depending on how big the file and how
quickly it's writing that to disk, of course.
What is that CPU that
jumped up? Let's see.
No. Because DD is a single core application,
one of the CPUs is now
essentially continuously just writing this big file. Oh,
and we can kinda I mean, again, the
desk is so large in this machine, 800
gig that but I do see a small
curve forming.
Right? Yeah.
Maybe not as quickly as I would have
laid, and the memory hasn't moved at all.
Wonder how we could eat up memory.
Let's see. Linux
consume
memory fast.
Googled no one ever.
So
I have a script that consumes a constant
amount of ram for a user to find
them in a time.
I mean, do we trust Stack Overflow?
I I always do blindly.
I mean that script looks really safe.
I mean if I understood it even remotely
maybe
I would do it. And this If I
could read it, it would be Oh.
Thanks.
So this one has some sort of imperative
loop. It does some multiplication,
and then evolves it.
I think that's just continually adding
to the rate. Let's see if we can
find one more before I trust that one.
I
mean, I tried to, like, dot dot go,
but it never gives me the answers I
want. So.
That's it's charm. Right?
And now Google is telling me how to
stop processes eating all my ram when I
actually want to cause a very explosive. I'm
just gonna trust it. Let's let's go with
this guy.
So
we'll get one more tab.
All of this just so I can see
a graph modify on the dashboard. That's it.
So
We could also
write data to Influx with Flux too, but
this is more fun because
you're just messing with things causing chaos.
Well, if I get it working, perhaps.
Am I supposed to oh, no. Wait. Because
the numbers aren't very big. Right?
That's not consuming RAM.
Whale through
to
okay.
That's maybe gonna consume some RAM.
Let's see. Let's see what Influx is.
Well, we'll find out in ten seconds.
This is gonna be so anticlimactic,
isn't it?
I don't know. We'll find out. I'm hopeful.
Oh, yes. I had a funny comment from
Nikolay who said, just install Slack.
Yeah. That would definitely eat around pretty fast,
wouldn't it? We do see
oh, no. That is kinda bending too. Okay.
I mean, we're still not really doing much
damage, but it's slowly we can see these
graphs being manipulated and we can see resources
being consumed.
Just not in the fun chaotic way that
I was kind of hoping.
Alright. Let's
do something a bit more practical then. That
was
that was okay. So we take a look
at the system dashboard that got generated for
us then. Is that gonna be a bit
better than mine?
Ours?
I guess we can find out. I think
that's subjective.
Yeah. Okay. Cool. So we've got system uptime,
which you can see if we could for
a eight CPUs.
We've got some system load here.
We got our memory.
Our memory. Yes. I mean, we're not even
at 1% memory usage, so and then we
got this guy over network processes and swap.
If we break us down to the last
five minutes, it'll look a little bit more
full. There we go and we can see
where we we we tried. Right? We tried
our best to consume a better load and
consume a better memory.
You maybe just
then
break down the the different cell types that
are available? Like, this is not a graph.
Right?
Yeah. So you have a variety of different
visualizations
both available to your explorer tab and also
your dashboard.
So you can add a cell and then
change the visualization where you can configure
individual cell to display a different visualization.
So let's do that. Let's click the gear
icon on any one of these cells.
And then, yeah, hit configure.
Yep. There you go. So there's heat maps,
histograms.
I really like the single stat on top
of the graph
graph plus single stat,
especially for things like memory and stuff like
that. I think it makes it
pretty powerful.
Probably not too useful, but I clicked on
one of those boarding ones though. Right? So
Yeah.
Let's use the desk IO since we managed
to get at least cause a little bit
of graphing there. There.
Well, what else did you say? We got
heat maps and histograms. You know, I've never
really understood the difference between when to use
a heat map or histogram.
You got any thoughts on that? Oh,
fascinating question.
Honestly,
no. I don't really ever use histograms.
Let's click on a heat map. Let's just
see if it speaks to us intuitively. Nope.
See? It doesn't.
I think if the visualization doesn't help you
understand what's going on, then it then it's
not the visualization for you.
Well, I mean, maybe that's not the visualization's
fault and just the fact that we have
less than twenty minutes worth of data that's
not really moving too much either. So, like,
I don't I don't think we're gonna get
particularly useful things. Like, there's like it's our
gauge. Right? It's like, hey, you're zero. Nice
work. Try harder. So
Yeah.
I mean, if I didn't have my rule
of doing everything live, perhaps I should have
spun one up earlier and left it running
for a few days with some weird workloads
on it. Or maybe a crypto miner. That
would have been a good idea. I mean,
we could always fork bomb the machine. That
would really cause some problems. Let's do that.
Are you familiar with a fork bomb?
I just it sounds good. So I'm excited.
So is this voodoo piece of bash
that
spawns
infinite processes until the machine falls over?
No.
Generally, the it may not like consume all
of the memory or the CPU,
but it will give us something interesting in
the processes table and we probably will run
out of pet IDs,
which is generally when the machine stops functioning.
And I don't even remember how it works
in practice because I haven't been stupid enough
to run it on my own machines for
a long time,
But we may have a better time to
run it
before it kills itself.
Why do people ever use it practically?
No. People don't. Okay.
Alright. Let's let's let's do this a little
bit safer. Right? Let's not I won't be
too chaotic. Let's get Docker installed.
Because there's a really cool feature with Docker
where we can limit the the pedal. We
can do a pedal limit so that it
won't destroy the machine.
So
let's do
command docker
image pool Alpine three.
In fact, it needs bash. Let's just do
bash.
Okay. So we should be able to do
a container run dash dash r m bash
echo hello.
Let's make sure the ped limit flag works
first.
Memory failure.
Pedsler.
Course.
No?
Oh, yeah.
What did I get wrong?
No space?
No equal sign?
No. No. I know.
Docker container.
Oh, no. It has to be after the
run.
Peds limit equals two.
Okay. So now we have
oh, my dog is going wild.
Oh, we need to pass that in as
a string, so let me re copy that.
This is a long way about just to
show something that's not even that exciting.
So
paste.
Copy it as one line.
Don't fail me now. I'll do it in
line. Okay.
I feel like I'm committed now.
Yeah. We have to see this through. Alright.
So now we're inside of a batch container.
Okay. Cool.
Now that wasn't very same because we only
ran it with a pad limit of two.
Let's let's see if we can visualize that.
I'm not gonna be able to visualize it
with two though, so let's bump it up.
Let's do 500.
Okay. And now it's setting the limit and
see if we get anything here.
We just need to wait ten seconds or
won't we?
Maybe we should do this from here.
And
this is the episode where we stopped looking
at Influx and instead just tried to break
the machine.
So
will that give me all fields? It does.
Okay.
Hey.
We did cause some artificial load. What is
the diff how many pets can we have?
Max, pets, Linux.
I don't wanna raise it and then find
out that I put it too high and
then we do destroy the machine.
4,000,000?
That's that's million. Right?
Yeah.
Yeah. Sure. Just yeah. Just agree. That's fine.
I
read 4,000,000. So
So we'll do 1,000,000.
And that's either the end of the episode
because we measure at the number
or
it'll just work.
Now it's not printing resource error yet.
And I've lost the machine.
And and now we have helpful comments from
people who are suggesting other ways to cause
artificial light.
Oh, no. The telegraph one. Okay. So it's
just I've just lost this window. So
maybe.
Yep. Okay. Telegraph is trying to exit nicely,
which is not very helpful right now.
Docker container l s.
Destroy
that container.
There, not too dangerous.
Come on.
Right. And then we'll do it the nice
way instead of that way.
Let's see what we see here though.
Oh, wow. Okay.
That's good. And then that's where we saved
it.
Now the
nicer way would have been this comment stress
n g which I'm not familiar with but
I guess we might as well check it
out.
Let's see what this does.
I'm assuming it needs some flags.
Right. Let's
forget that. That was a nice
digression,
I guess.
So we also have this InfluxDB two OSS
dashboard. This is what using the internal metrics?
Yeah.
So
there's a
InfluxDB OSS, and then there's also a free
tier. So hot tip, if you are using
either or use one to monitor your own
InfluxDB instance as well.
Okay.
Now as a do I have to build
all these dashboards myself? Is there somewhere I
can get more of these pre canned ones?
There is
a community templates repo and InfluxData,
and there's a bunch of temp we should
actually test the template I just
just merged yesterday.
So
this one? Mhmm.
And what was your template called?
InfluxDB
two operational
metrics.
There you go. I think you just passed
it.
So I just copy this YAML?
So you can just copy the URL actually.
And then
go to
settings
and then templates.
And then in and then click the copy
and paste. Yeah.
Okay. So this is gonna create
some task summary dashboards, some cardinality explorer.
We've got
bucket. We've got a task and then some
labels. Okay. I'll trust it.
Let's go and see what we have then.
So I don't know. I think we're gonna
have to change the frequency at which we're
writing today. So we created a cardinality task
as a part of this
template. So let's change that cardinality by bucket
every period and make it less than an
hour. Maybe make it
ten seconds
or thirty
seconds or something. So we actually start getting
some data.
Says fail. Let's find out why.
How do we do that?
So we can either can we I think
if we click
on yeah. Let's try clicking on that view.
There we go.
View logs. Why'd you fail?
Can you make it a little bigger, please?
Oh, perfect. Okay.
Requires host to be specified.
Maybe I shouldn't have picked a
template that I just
added,
But we could try to debug it. I
could go to
the task and see what they mean by
oh, wait. But part of this is a
task failure
monitoring template. So maybe that'll give us more
information as to why this is failing.
InfluxDB.
What does it mean problem with
host isn't identified?
I don't know. Let me look at the
header. I should have been paying more attention.
So
cannot execute task run run time map fail
to evaluate map function.
And so it says the InfluxDB provider requires
a host to be specified.
So
to me, that means that
this needs some configuration.
Maybe maybe here.
Does this have a open plate?
I'll
look at the InfluxDB cardinality package.
I'm not sure.
Why don't we just write our own task?
Yeah. We should just write our own task.
Oh, you can specify. Yeah. Does that work
when you specify the host?
There's a parameter for that. Alright. Okay. Let's
let's see.
12702021.
Save.
Can I just force a run? Yeah. There
we go.
Oh, it wants the port number in the
host. Okay.
I can fix that.
8086.
Might as well just protocol two.
Force run.
Unauthorized.
Oh, so you need to include your organization
and your token.
Okay.
Tokens.
Copy.
Alright. So organization.
It's just org.
Yeah.
Token.
Okay.
Or and can I just be the name?
Mhmm.
Run.
Oh.
Requires a host to be specified.
Alright. Let's write our own task then. Okay.
Let's do that.
So let's say we wanna downsample
our CPU.
Mhmm.
Let's run this every well, let's do every
ten seconds for quickness.
So
Do we wanna write it from scratch or
let the UI write it for us?
I feel like I should say UI. So
Okay.
I guess we just find the measurement we
want.
Let's do system.
K.
Do I just copy the script? Or Yeah.
Or do you wanna I think we're just
doing a window aggregation. Do we maybe wanna
find a metric that's a little bit more
obvious? Like, I think we should do it
maybe, like, return the max.
So I would just go to the script
editor.
Like that? I would just go to the
script editor and then
remove aggregate window and just create max instead.
Like that? Mhmm.
Is that what we want? That's that's what
I want.
Alright. So I I copy this and then
we just go to the task here? Yeah.
Or no. You can click save as. Oh,
sorry. Go back to the explorer.
And then you can click save as.
And then you can say
a task.
Ah, okay. So downsample
CPU
run every thirty seconds.
I guess we can just use that bucket
since it's there. I don't think there's any
data in it. I I was trying to
use that that cardinality task to write
data from your Rawkode
bucket to the cardinality bucket about
your
cardinality,
but I obviously need to fix something. So
We can start to reuse the cardinality bucket,
and we'll just download sample CPU into it.
So if I hit save Oh, the output.
Got it. Yeah. And
we'll run this manually now.
What we should see is
something.
I'm not sure. Let's see. Current oh, yeah.
CPU.
We got UC system.
And we probably only got one point right
now because it's only run
once.
Is that why it's not
graphable?
I think it's because it's finding if if
you do a group, maybe you'll find that
you'll be able to
on time. I would just do a plain
group without any columns.
Oh, that's why. Because it automatically added a
our window too. So
oh, yeah. I don't think you wanna group.
I changed my mind.
Ungroup. Ungroup.
No. I like the group. You do? Okay.
Alright.
Okay. So we get a max value at
least.
I think we we just don't have a
lot of data. But I I think that's
really cool anyway. So we have
I don't know we could do that for
the UI which I also really like. So
we have a Rawkode bucket right in ten
second granularity
usage data,
which looks like this. We then created a
query to
fetch the max value of that over a
given window.
And that is now being written to the
cardinality bucket
here.
And we do have points, but we just
don't have a lot of data in here
yet. No.
I guess we could speed the task up,
but I guess that's not particularly important.
Do you wanna walk us through the process
of alerting on that max going above a
certain value?
Sure.
So we can just go to the alerts
tab,
and then
I think it'd be useful to create a
threshold alert here.
And I guess we'll just make one to
fail to start with.
Do we wanna alert on our dance sample
data or our raw data? I think we
should alert on our raw data.
Yeah. I guess
the dance sample data is really for
longer term analytics and look back whereas we'd
wanna we'd want the real high resolution data
for the alert. Right? Yeah.
Okay.
So if we find a max
Now we can just click on a threshold
basically on the graph.
Once we click configure
configure check, the next tab.
Oh.
I'm just clicking now. I don't okay. Critical.
There we go. Yeah. There you go. Yeah.
Alright. So if we keep this relatively low,
we should be able to trigger that
not with another thought on, but, you know,
with with something else.
So did I just click
done?
I I believe so. Yeah.
And then I see a tab for endpoints.
Let's use HTTP.
There's this thing called Rbox.
App which is really cool. Which just gives
you like an endpoint you can throw arbitrary
payloads to.
R box.
And then rules.
What do I do here?
I think you can just like, this is
where you
change the conditions as well as
add more information about what's happening. Like, I
think you can specify.
Okay. So
a rule being that every five seconds,
if we see something in
critical,
notify
the standpoint.
Yeah.
Done.
Cool. Let's make
the CPU or
surpass our threshold.
Okay.
Let's try.
And then do I want it? Yeah. Let's
find an example of stress n g rather
than me running that thing again. So stress
n g example.
Because we had it recommended to us, so
we should we should use it.
I thought that was really neat how you
also
shared the the comment with everybody.
This is a cool tool.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. I really like this.
Okay. I mean, I've just copy and pasted
that. I don't know what one matrix is.
I'm assuming the dash t one minute means
run it for one minute. Oh, yeah. And
we also got another.
You're very helpful today. Thank you, Nicolas.
Stress n g dash dash CPU. What did
I do? Yeah. Let's let's just document. So
dash dash CPU.
Let's how many CPUs do I have?
Try again.
I have
48.
So dash dash CPU,
Alright.
So that means
should we view this from here first? So
we should be able to see on our
CPU metrics here.
System.
I'm still seeing this comment, so it's hard
for me to Oh.
There we go. Thank you. So while the
tool is really cool, sadly, it's still operated
by an idiot. So we we do our
best.
Now
yeah. Our CPU is
it's claiming there. So that should mean
my alert should
be firing.
Yeah. It looks like it's got a green
check. So
Is that good or bad? That looks good.
Let's click on the I I eye icon.
Oh, that's hard to say.
I don't know. Yeah.
Which CPU metric are we alerting on, though?
I thought we were alerting on all of
them. No? I don't know. Let's find out.
You said system.
We're learning on all of them.
And that's what I created here.
Oh, no. You should use our ah, okay.
So let's change that.
User.
There we go.
So can I We we can't? We just
had to wait the ten seconds, won't we?
Mhmm. So if you do you did you
bring a joke? If you got a joke?
I only have the world's worst pun or
like dad joke, but it's so Texas for
specific.
So what did
how did Davy Crockett like his pie?
Do know who Davy Crockett is? Yeah. I'm
familiar. Okay. L mode.
So that updated a few seconds ago. We
have a green tech. I don't know if
the green tech is good too. It just
means it's check ran or it's failing.
I guess the rule would be
I think it says that it's running
successfully. And then if you look at the
history,
we'll see that it I think it's failing.
Oh, yeah. So
that means
I refresh this bit. Ah, there we go.
We have old oh, wow.
So I I know. Obviously, that HTTP
web hook thing is entirely contrived,
but, you know, that could be PagerDuty,
Opsgenie, Slack, whatever tool people are using.
Let's stop that stress testing tool.
Alright. So what did we do? We
used a quick start. We got a telegraph
config for free. We start to collect the
data of a telegraph.
We
went down the wrong path and started playing
with the FortBomb stuff,
trying to make our graphs look a bit
more interesting.
And I failed miserably, but we did manage
to cover a few cool features there as
well. Let me just pull this back up,
see if it's any more interesting.
Bucket.
And
then we
imported a dashboard,
which was nice.
It didn't work, but well,
we then then sampled some data
from the Rawkode bucket and our cardinality bucket.
That was relatively easy to do. I didn't
I I wasn't familiar. I didn't remember that
we could just do that from the query
builder and then save that to a task.
That was a really nice touch.
And then we configured an alert in back
end and we start to send an alert
space on
again, a contrived situation of just making that
CPU spikes to the ref.
Did I miss anything? No. That was perfect
summary.
Is there anything else you wanna show before
we finish up for the day?
That's a great question.
I think that
feels pretty well rounded,
so I'm inclined to say
to say no.
Right. Yeah. I mean, I think the best
we forgot the best feature which is toggle
on the dashboard onto the other mode. Anyway,
I was so impressed when that came out
for a while and then realized I don't
like bright colors. But, you know.
Okay. Well, that was a good fun. I
think it was nice to explore and FluxDB
to take a look at Flux and
and just see what's coming out of that
space. It was GA last week, so people
should I guess start to play with this.
If they have any problems, I'm assuming they
can just come and speak to you. Right?
Yeah. So we have a Slack channel and
a community forum as well. So
come find us. Come come ask questions.
The community forum, there's a there's a little
if you want immediate response from somebody, I
would recommend going to Slack.
But if you
have a more complicated question
or you wanna brag about a solution you
found, you should just post it on the
community forum.
Alright. Awesome.
We got one final comment there, which I'm
hoping is in relation to the the theme
change, but, know you know,
some people like it, some people hate it.
Anyway, thank you for joining me today, Annie.
I will speak to you soon, and I
hope you have a great day. Thank you.
Thank you for having me. Thanks. Bye.